here we go what are the three things
you're gonna be looking for in this
democratic debate go I'm looking for wit
I'm looking for insight and I'm looking
for wisdom I'm looking to see if it's
interesting at all because I can imagine
it being very quiet sort of boring
affair where everyone just recites their
talking points I think what a lot of
Democratic primary voters not that thing
she'll did it i think they looking for
sort of specific a lot of one looked for
a lot of 123 stuff the challenge for
Hillary Clinton is to run as a
front-runner but still be ineffective
debater I think that back in two
thousand eight she was great when she
was running from behind and she
basically won all the debates against
Obama except for the one where she had
the driver's license issue so this time
around we'll see I want her to be able
to give voice to the frustration that
she feels when she talks to people who
are stuck and I want that to come out
from her number two how sharp through
martin O'Malley's elbows get trying to
make himself relevant in this race I'm
actually interested see if if O'Malley
will hit Clinton or if he'll be nice I
expect the candidate to particularly
Sanders and Clinton to stay in their
lanes did I might bump a little bit
against each other but not as much
obviously O'Malley and then we'll be
bumping a lot more number two actually I
want to hear all of them talk more about
national security I Jim Webb has past
experience with it I don't know about
the others obviously Hillary wrote a
whole book about it was our Secretary of
State but I want to know about national
security number three does Bernie
Sanders comb his hair for it I'll be
interested to see no offense to hair
challenged people I guess I'm the third
thing is I'm looking to see what like
are there other candidates on stage like
like is Jim Webb gonna talk is he going
to this debate the third thing did she
look far as you know what to say in
sports intangibles how does it come
across from stage you know who sort of
stands out number three
number three a little humor you know
wouldn't kill us on the Democratic side
have a little humor who has more at
stake in this debate I think Hillary
does because she's the front-runner
always I think she does I mean it's just
because they did everything that happens
it is you know every word that she
utters is going to be you know instantly
fact-check instantly put through a thing
to say what did she say something
different you know 10 years ago it's
going to be digested and scrutinized who
has the most at stake in this debate
think of martin O'Malley the three guys
who are one percent this is their last
and only chance i know you will remember
very well what happened hillary clinton
a debates against your former boss in
october of two thousand drivers late
october two thousand seven does anyone
here believe an illegal immigrant should
not have a driver's license I did not
say that it should be done but I
certainly recognized what governor
Spitzer is trying to do it when we have
failed we have failed no no you said you
said yes no thought it made sense to do
it no I didn't Christmas so do you not
think that there's some risk that
because of the focus on her that if she
stumbles once it makes one error that it
could be a hugely horrible night for her
if that happens given the way the press
treats her yes I mean I'm sure I'm sure
if she makes any kind of even the
smallest error it will be magnified way
more than it should be it's always been
the case and I think she's actually in
position to have a pretty good week she
did you know she's going to be
thoroughly prepared the whole Benghazi
email thing is falling apart if she
makes one error that will be the story
if she screws up one question that will
be the story is that not a huge risk for
her it is but so what she's running for
president you know what the seriously
when she went to chipotle it was a
rescue like everything she does it is
not fair but it is real the standards
for her are far far higher I think she
can't go into the debate with that
mindset I think part of what to the
extent that she hasn't done as well as
some people hope it is as a result of
excessive caution and if you allow fear
to govern you in these things then you
you're gonna be tight end and that in
and of itself creates a problem okay
what's your one piece of advice to
Bernie Sanders keep staying positive be
human be Bernie Sanders keep what you're
doing on the stump don't attack it's not
in his interest not that I love Hillary
nobody's above attack okay nobody should
be immune from criticism but part of why
he's catching fire is he's not parroting
Donald Trump he it's not an insult comic
he is running really powerful ideas and
I would say he was stay in your lane man
stick with what got you here would you
one piece of advice to martin O'Malley
well give it your best shot because
you're you're in extreme jeopardy here
you gotta distinguish yourself somehow
someway between the two frontrunners
don't try to make a circus act out of
the debate I think that you will he is a
very tough path and that there is
basically no path unless there's some
extraordinary external event that
happens and just try to get people who
are Democrats to like you does he need
to take a big swing try to get noticed
or does he lay lay low I think he needs
to he needs to probably stress the
generational argument which is the
comparative advantage that probably
works best for him on that stage for
O'Malley you've gotta you gotta start
attacking the rest of the other
candidates you gotta start drying
contrast by the rest of the Canada lose
even if it'll lose at that point by the
rest of the other candidate you mean
Hillary Clinton I mean probably you
would not advise O'Malley to like try to
take Clinton out in this debate or try
to actually go negative in a harsh way
no because I think that that would
alienate a lot of people I think there
are probably a core group of Sanders
supporters who would love for somebody
to take off the gloves on Hillary
Clinton but I don't think that for the
majority of the party that there's a
real appetite we gotta remember the
democratic party Republican Party had
two different parties the Democrats you
did the worst thing that happened in 08
is sorta I like you well enough Hilary
honey I mean they're not they like
everybody in the party has 75% approvals
I mean you're in order to take somebody
on you take it on somebody's popular
wellness the other side of the equation
they don't like their part it almost
like that leadership not even crazy
about their own County so I think it's
you know I mean you know you can
obliquely you know get some look I on
Wall Street I you know that that kind of
stuff but it again that's what I'm
saying in the lane there'll be some
bumping you know it's going to be more
like a you know a horse race yet again
then buff it in a stretch but you can't
you can't just cut in front of somebody